[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program with the David Horowitz freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy recently ivan ball hatchet the
british national police chief's
council's lead on honor violence was
asked by a former police officer why
there had not yet been a single
conviction for female genital mutilation
FGM in the entire United Kingdom despite
their having than tens of thousands of
cases of it recorded since 1985 while
hatchets response
unwittingly revealed the priorities of
Theresa Mays diverse shattered
staggering
Dimmie Britain amid a great deal of
meaningless bureaucratic verbiage while
hatchet let it slip by way of
explanation that there are many nuances
to this crime type so apparently it is
because of these many nuances that
practitioners of female genital
mutilation could continue to operate
with impunity in Britain why not arrest
them it's complicated in reality it
isn't complicated at all and there
aren't many nuances either no vile
hatchet there's only one nuance and you
and I and Teresa may and all of Britain
knows what that one nuance is the people
who practice FGM are Muslims and you
don't want to offend them and so you
don't prosecute FGM cases it isn't
really any more nuanced than that
although you will batter your
interlocutors with all manner of baffle
gab to try to cover up that fact
Ivan ball hatchet and the UK press will
never admit it but FGM is an Islamic
practice sanctioned by Islamic law and
practiced by non-muslims only in areas
where there is a heavy Muslim presence a
manual of Islamic law states this
circumcision is obligatory for every
male and female and it goes on to say
circumcision of the female is by cutting
out the clitoris this is called coup
Fahd female circumcision that's from a
Shafi'i manual of Islamic law reliance
of the traveler section II for number
three FGM is widespread in 30 Muslim
countries so when Ivan Bal hatchet says
that he hasn't prosecuted thousands of
cases of FGM because of nuance he means
inbred
today the Muslims are in charge this is
not the first time that Baal hatchet has
revealed this either he showed it in
November regarding honor killing when he
likewise DEQ's cues to the low number of
prosecutions of this crime
he said honor based abuse is a complex
crime which often happens within
community or family networks that many
victims find it very difficult to speak
out against and can face further threats
violence or isolation if they do in all
cases our priority is to safeguard
vulnerable victims from this appalling
form of abuse so we work to put
protection orders in place as soon as
possible even where a conviction is not
possible so he can put protection orders
in place but not get a conviction how
does that make sense who are these women
being protected from anyway and why here
again baal hatchet is really dragging
his feet because the crime in question
is inextricably bound up with Islam
Muslims commit 91 percent of honor
killings worldwide the Palestinian
Authority gives pardons or suspended
sentences for honor murders Iraqi women
have asked for tougher sentences for
Islamic Honour murderers who get off
lightly now Syria in 2009 scrapped a law
limiting the length of sentences for
honor killings but the new law says a
man can still benefit from extenuating
circumstances in crimes of passion or
honor provided he serves a prison term
of no less than two years in the case of
killing and in 2003 the Jordanian
Parliament voted down on Islamic grounds
a provision designed to stiffen
penalties for honor killings al Jazeera
reported that Islamists and
conservatives said the laws violated
religious traditions and would destroy
families and values as Ivan Baal hatchet
wrestles in vain with all this nuance
and complexity tens of thousands of
girls and women and women in the United
Kingdom are murdered or condemned to
lives of misery and pain but that is the
price of having a multicultural and
diverse society these days and so this
witless functionary Baal hatchet is
likely still to be puzzling about all
the dizzying intricacies of prosecuting
crimes such as FGM and honor killing at
the very moment when in the new Sharia
UK they are D criminal
altogether I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]